jackie for more on the crisis at our
southern border we are joined by a
republican senator from tennessee and
member of the senate armed services and
commerce committees marcia blackburn
senator thank you for taking time you
heard brian janice's great report there
he went into pierre pierre's negros in
2018 i followed a caravan all the way
from san pedro honduras seven thousand
miles to the u.s they ended up in
piedras negras they were there and
crossed into eagle pass what we may see
now if title 42 goes away is going to be
10 times what we saw four years ago what
do you make of this and what should be
done
what should be done is that title 42
should be kept and griff as you're
mentioning and as brian mentioned in his
report you look at how the numbers have
escalated under joe biden
with title 42 in place and the
expectation that you will go from 6 000
to 7 800 to 18 000 per day
now when i heard that 18 000 figure i
looked at the total number of towns we
have in tennessee which is 345.
of those 345 towns and cities 90
of them
are 18 000 or fewer people per day
so this would be the equivalent of the
population of a typical tennessee town
coming across the border
every single day of the week
we cannot afford to do this
it is something that is a danger to the
sovereignty and the security of our
nation and crime in the streets drugs on
the streets human trafficking gangs sex
trafficking some of those are the
biggest problems that our law
enforcement and our community leaders
talk about they're having to address
every town's a border town every state
is a border state
but senator outsiders legal court action
what what can republicans in the
minority do to try and stop this from
happening
we can look at the funding mechanisms
and make certain that there is no money
for uh for title 42 for the removal of
title 42. we also can look at expanding
title 42 and there is bipartisan support
for keeping that forcing that issue
forcing a floor vote making certain that
title 42 covers drugs
and gives extra ability to go after
these drug traffickers i was down in
benton county tennessee yesterday over
in the northwest part of the state and
our
sheriff over there sheriff christopher
was talking about the presence of
fentanyl and how prevalent that has been
they've seen such an uptick in the past
six months and he said if we can't
secure that southern border that when
those drug dealers come across it's like
a a a shotgun blast you know it spreads
everywhere
it is indeed and just in the time we
have left i want to ask you also about
another story and that is the
administration's new disinformation
czar nina jankowicz your thoughts and
reactions to that
what we know is that this disinformation
governance board is put there to allow
the biden administration
to
censor political free speech what they
are trying to do is take away your free
speech and this is someone who has shown
that they are very partisan uh that she
is going to take a partisan approach we
know that she believes christopher
steele is a really great guy
and she also believes that hunter
biden's laptop is russian disinformation
but by the way she was to be a
broadway musical singing expert on
russia disinformation we see what that
has gotten us
well she has certainly created quite a
stir senator marsha blackburn thank you
for taking time have a great rest of
your saturday